I have disturbing video for you today of
Ron DeSantis appearing on Fox News
with a kid
who says that masks are bad basically
and this looks like a hostage video it
it looks like I mean listen I'm gonna
play it for you it's only 10 seconds
we'll look at it a couple of times this
looks like a hostage video where the kid
barely has any idea what they're being
forced to say and Ron DeSantis
Republican Florida Governor
um looks so smug
let's just look and listen to this um
and then then we'll see if we can make
heads or tails out of it go ahead I'm
not wearing a mask because you touch it
and you have germs on your hand and then
face and breathe in all the germs that's
right and and all right so okay and
listen there's Steve Ducey I think
saying that's right that's right so
uh this is Fiona lachelle's a second
grader in Florida
and of course when we think about public
policy my instinct always is ask one
second grader what they think and make
that the policy now something about this
video is extremely disturbing but many
things about the video are extremely
disturbing Republicans seem to have
found a way to put kids front and center
on masks
and not wanting them notice that they
never put front and center the kids of
parents who died unvaccinated of covid
I wish they got the same prominent
placement as Fiona lachelle's saying I
don't want to wear the mask let's listen
to it one more time go ahead I'm not
wearing a mask because you touch it and
you have germs on your hand and then you
put it on your face and breathe in all
the germs and Ron DeSantis just looks so
thrilled now it's been we we have two
options we could ask a second grader
hand-picked by Ron DeSantis their
opinion of masks or we could look at the
studies
um endless endless endless studies on
this do face masks work 49 scientific
studies explain why they do you can go
to
Jama insights they have a meta-analysis
called effectiveness of mask squaring to
control Community spread of SARS cov2
they actually look at all of these
different studies and they find
significant decreases in the spread of
coven it you can download this it's a
free study you can find it and they
write increasing number of ecological
studies also provide persuasive evidence
that Universal masking reduces the
number of infections and deaths these
studies don't distinguish the type of
masks but they all seem to work to some
degree the overall Community benefit of
wearing masks derives from their ability
to limit both exhalation and inhalation
of infectious virus the science on masks
and then a second grader hand-picked by
Ron DeSantis sorry about that
um let's listen to it one more time this
is is this child abuse in some way go
ahead I'm not wearing a mask because you
touch it and you have germs on your hand
and then you put it on your face and
breathe in all the germs yeah and that's
importantly this is a second grader
suspended 36 days for not wearing a mask
one just little bonus clip for you from
Flora just to tell you how crazy things
in Florida are this is 14 seconds of a
video of Ron DeSantis announcing he's
going to create an office to investigate
election crimes in Florida what crimes
are even being alleged in Florida
election crimes I don't know Trump won
Florida by three and a half
no one's even really talking about
Florida fraud and when Ron DeSantis
announces so so think about the layers
DeSantis mishandles covid
announces he's creating an office to
investigate election crimes which we
don't need
and then the crowd starts cheering and
chanting let's go Brandon
[Applause]
just completely cringy now if you don't
know about let's go Brandon it goes back
to a NASCAR race during which uh there
were people in the crowd during an
interview chanting F Joe Biden And the
reporter misheard it she was
interviewing a race car driver named
Brandon and she said look they're
chanting let's go Brandon but really
they were chanting F Joe Biden that's
where it comes from it's it's not very
funny
um it's almost like a rallying Cry of
ignorance and stupidity but when Ron it
it's fitting that Ron DeSantis announces
an investigation into something we don't
need and the crowd starts chanting let's
go Brandon so just horrifying horrifying
stuff happening in Florida we've got a
great show for you today let me know
your thoughts on the DeSantis uh child
hostage video you can find me on Twitter
at D Pacman we're going to take some of
your calls look at some of your emails
and many many exciting things happening
today
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee for sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20
000 five-star reviews and best of all if
you don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video